avec nos creissen groupe présidente de
l'ordre des psychologues du québec
bonsoir madame gros
comme vous vous parlez a évidemment
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
psychologues qui sont débordés comment
d'abord vous qualifie cette vague de
d'anxiété de troubles qui déferle
actuellement la urnes et celle de 10,3 à
combien
on est rendu à une intolérance à c'est
lui je vous dirais probablement
probablement plus
7.58 qu'on l'était l'an dernier mais
vous savez l'anxiété est la montée dès
le début de la pandémie
elle et elle est demeurée je pense qu'on
peut qualifier la dernière vague comme
étant un peu la vague de trop parce que
si la vague de la fatigue pandémique il
ya quelqu'un dans le reportage qui
parlait des réserves qui sont limitées
je pense qu'on avait tous des réserves
mais effectivement on a tous aussi des
limites à nos capacités adaptatives
alors les gens sont fatigués le cerveau
est fatigué et quand le cerveau est
fatigué il faire un peu sa perspective
et il a l'impression que les choses sont
plus simples qu'elles ne le sont c'est
ça on voit pas la lumière pour reprendre
l'expression à la mode on voit pas la
lumière au bout du tunnel parfois on
n'est pas capable et pour la frange
la plus
la plus sensible en tout cas qui a le
plus de problèmes cet homme dans le
reportage d'une phrase très importante
il le dit moi j'ai les moyens j'ai pu
aller chercher de la javel et robin
dessus très grave je peux pas imaginer
si j'avais pas été vu par un
professionnel les gens qui n'ont pas les
moyens madame groupe comment font-ils
pour avoir de l'aide actuellement
bah écoutez c'est ça qui est dramatique
les gens qui n'ont pas les moyens ou les
ressources parce que ça prend des avoirs
ça prendre connaissance du système ça
fend des ressources psychologiques même
pour aller chercher de line et il ya des
populations qui sont plus vulnérables
effectivement qui ont moins de moyens
financiers mais moins de moyens tout
court aussi et je pense qu'il faut
s'occuper de ces gens là je pense qu'il
va falloir à un moment donné qui est
assez rapidement faire de la santé
mentale un enjeu de santé publique puis
m même énergie la même la même vitesse
de traitement pour donner accès aux gens
qu'on le fait par exemple pour essayer
d'enrayer la contagion mais quand
monsieur carmat annonce aujourd'hui un
point 1 milliards sur cinq ans qui va
avoir 3 175 millions de plus pour
ajouter des ressources est-ce que ça ça
vous rassure très concrètement est ce
qu'il y aura plus de psychologues qui
vont aller travailler au public d'après
vous madame comme ça c'est la partie qui
m'inquiète car il ya en fait il ya des
aspects des points forts de ce plan
d'action là d'avoir eu les quintés re
ministériel est une première c'est un
plan d'action pour faire la promotion et
la sensibilisation de la santé mentale
donc été grandement temps qu'on le fasse
on veut cibler les jeunes aussi on veut
faire des partenariats avec la
communauté et ça c'est très bien
là la partie sur le traitement sur
l'accès aux services psychologiques sur
l'accès à la psychothérapie devant je ne
la vois pas comme je ne vois pas qu'est
ce qu'on va faire pour garder attiré
garder les psychologues dans le réseau
public parce qu'actuellement
effectivement ça devienne pénurie et on
va avoir besoin d'eux pour traiter la
population moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est
qu'on a un enjeu d'accès à ses services
que pour la population et si on a un
enjeu d'accès aux services
psychologiques mais malheureusement on
va diminuer la qualité des soins
pourquoi un finish un doctorant qui
entrent au public comme psychologue n'y
restent pas monaco
il ya 2 juillet deux éléments en fait
qui sont fondamentaux le premier si les
conditions de pratique alors évidemment
doctorants il étudie bien des années à
l'université donc en moyenne 8 ans et
les conditions dans lesquelles on le met
actuellement ou l'approbation
d'autonomie professionnels sont des
irritants comme le manque de
reconnaissance comme le manque d'accès
de la formation spécialisée ou un
gestionnaire de proximité qui comprend
ce que c'est un psychologue fait il ya
également les conditions salariales puis
vous savez pertinemment que moi comme
président de hordes je ne les lis
négocie pas les conditions salariales
mais par ailleurs ça devient iata parce
que ça cause un enjeu d'accès à ces
services là la population et je pense
que on va avoir un problème et si on
sort
donc de façon très concrète quelqu'un au
public qui appelle au clc qui veut un
rendez vous avec un psychologue une
psychologue dans ce qui a été annoncé ce
matin par le ministre à ce que le temps
d'attendre est de diminuer de 2 à 6 mois
où vous voyez pas beaucoup de vraiment
positif pour réduire le temps d'attendre
mais d'abord il faut comprendre que si
vous vous adressez demain matin à ses
lacets pour pour obtenir une
psychothérapie ou pour avoir accès à
quelqu'un qui peut offrir une
psychothérapie ya bien des clsc ou le
service n'existe pas alors donc avant
même de s'adresser autant d'attentes il
faudrait s'assurer qu'on a les effectifs
et je voudrais maintenant et
communautaires parce qu'on veut regarnir
les services communautaires et les
patients ce qu'ils demandent souvent c
mais on veut avoir des gens avec qui
parler on va avoir déjà pour vous
écouter et non pas uniquement
une
médication par exemple donc ils ont
besoin dans l'église ont besoin d'un
facteur humain et je pense que il faut
se pencher puis vous savez loin de moi
l'idée de dire qu' au que les services
psychologiques qui sont nécessaires ça
prend un ensemble de services pourraient
jouer la provocation santé mentale et ça
fait partie du plan d'action combinée
mais je ne vois pas la portion où on
veut rehausser qui même ramené à ce que
c'était il ya une dizaine d'années au
regard des effectifs psychologie combien
y manque madame groupe de psychologues
au québec indépendamment privé public là
mais quand communément pour offrir des
services aux gens qui en ont besoin
c'est difficile de dire qui en manque
parce qu'on garde quand même le plus
grand ratio de psychologues père
capitaine amérique du nord donc on ne me
le psychologue dans le réseau public
évidemment il ya un an on en a perdu
dans la dernière décennie presque 456
qu'est ce qui est ce qui est
problématique actuellement c'est que il
y a que 25 % des doctorants qui
accepte un emploi dans le réseau public
et de ses 25% là il y en a 40 % qui ok
tu es dans les cinq années qui suivent
leur embauche et ça c'était pas le cas
donc pour le privé vous dites il y en a
assez même si on entendait dans le
reportage et puis que dire nos listes
d'attentes on fermait menées au
téléphone parce qu'on a trop de manques
mais c'est tout à fait juste se dire que
l'on est dans une situation sans
précédent
moi j'ai jamais vu ça du gym avant on
disait au moins quand les gens ont de
l'argent ce qui était pas décemment
équitable mais ils peuvent aller se
faire soigner alors que maintenant même
si c'est le coq c'est très difficile
d'avoir accès et c'est parce que
justement la santé mentale de la
population a été mise à mal donc on le
travaille sur la lune l'accessibilité
aux services compétents je pense que
maintenant il faut chercher de toutes
les façons possibles dans le plan
d'action il ya plusieurs éléments très
positifs qui vont permettre d'avoir un
accès faut juste pas oublié cette
portion de service qui fait partie des
demandes populationnelle et docteur
clairement me parler aux 17 heures jeux
les reçus à mon émission du but alors
qu'on va moderniser qu'est ce que vous
en dites vous y aurait une porte
d'entrée d'ailleurs je le dis aux gens
que j'avais des problèmes voulait parler
à quelqu'un a fait le retard ils doivent
en principe vous aiguillonner vers
quelque chose de concret est-ce que ça
c'est bien
mais c'est très bien dans la mesure où
quand on appelle aux huit ans on parle à
quelqu'un qui est en mesure d'évaluer
adéquatement
mais là souvent ça va être comme un
dépistage mais pour orienter quelqu'un
déjà faut avoir évalué en partie le
problème dont la personne a besoin qu'il
faut être capable d'offrir le service
dont la personne a besoin et non pas
services disponibles et je pense que ça
fait partie de la volonté du plan
d'action mais ça fait long feu en france
on veut offrir le bon service à la
personne hamon au moment opportun bon
ben chris huhne grove espérer que ça
bouge encore plus vite merci parce que
c'est on voit moins ça c'est sûr que
dans les statistiques ya pas de tableau
à chaque jour où on dira troubles
anxieux mais sa débauche aura aussi
parfois des
hospitalisations et ses autres notre
tout ce qui ne se prêtent pas risque de
s'aggraver de se complexifier c'est très
payant de traiter au moma et rapidement
quelqu'un qui a des problèmes de santé
mentale la saison merci madame rouge un
président de l'ordre des psychologues du
québec merci nous avons parlé